und jetzt muss ich nicht erst mal wieder
aufregen wir haben hier ein
biomineralwasser 0,5 liter für drei euro
24 und wir haben hier 0,25 liter milch
für zwei euro 79 junge in welcher
galaxie lebt hier
hey leute was geht ab und herzlich
willkommen beim ein video ja leute ich
hoffe natürlich geht es gut aber zu
sagen die leute ja alex du schreibst du
mit den videos deswegen wollte ich heute
mal ein bisschen langsamer anfangen egal
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch geht's
gut ich weiß von mir kam jetzt längere
zeit kein video wir haben jetzt heute
montag thema wir haben fast 12 uhr
ja wir haben 23 uhr 49 ich bin gestern
zurück gekommen ich war ja im skiurlaub
heute und ja ich bin heute zurück nach
köln gefahren ich bin vor einer stunde
ungefähr angekommen die haben echt schon
spät krass auf jeden fall war das auch
der grund warum ist jetzt irgendwie echt
45 tage kein video kam es tut mir sehr
leid aber ich habe es leider nicht
hinbekommen weil ich einfach keine zeit
dafür hatte und ich mir gedacht habe
wenn du jetzt schon hier im urlaub ist
danach einfach urlaub und legt alles war
so schön beiseite weil man muss aber
sagen youtube ist schon fulltime-job man
hat es immer im korb
das kam schon echt anstrengend sein aber
natürlich hat es auch sehr viele
vorteile wie zum beispiel dieses geniale
video was ich da ist geht mit diesem
stuhl was ich eigentlich gar nicht
unbedingt machen wollte aber so viele
von euch haben gesagt allerdings macht
das doch bitte und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht passt auf ich hab was mache ich
jetzt werde ich habe jetzt gerade mal
eine menge hunger weil ich heute erst
kuchen und ein teller nudeln gegessen
habe das war es ich bin auch erst mal 12
uhr aufgestanden weil ich viel schlaf
nachholen musste aber so wirklich die
benötigten kalorien sind noch nicht drin
deswegen bestellen heute 100 prozent zu
weil ich auf märkte und nehmen bei
mcdonald's auf lieferheld.de ja so viele
wollten dieses video haben ich habe mir
gedacht komm viele von euch an
wahrscheinlich ein burger king park
gesehen ich habe noch nicht bei mcdonald
bestellt weil macdonald eigentlich gar
nicht hier hin liefert durch bohne
die liefern irgendwie glaube ich fast
traum in köln bergen hat schon deswegen
müssen wir heute die pick up version
machen ja ich bin hier auf der
wunderschönen seite lieferheld da war
ich vorher wirklich noch nie drauf ich
habe noch nie
im leben über lieferheld bestellt
allerdings habe ich einfach nichts
anderes gefunden und das hier sind die
produkte die man anscheinend doppelpack
menü bürger der wie schon gesagt wir
müssen das leider pickup so nennt sich
das hier die liefert das leider nicht
bis zu meiner haustür
das ist schon mal ein fetter minuspunkt
aber der weg ist ist gar nicht so weit
von mir entfernt deswegen sollte das
okay sein finde ich und da wird schon so
später habe ich echte menge hunger habt
fangen wir sofort mal an prinzip ist
natürlich wie immer ich habe hier meine
zufallsgenerator app daraus würfeln wir
erst eine kategorie und aus der
kategorie dann ein produkt ihr kennst du
mittlerweile und wenn ihr bock habt auch
noch ein paar zum beispiel keine ahnung
ob ich noch nicht bestellt boehner 100%
zufällig könnte man auch machen dass wir
dann wieder so einen lieferservice
aktionen lassen doch nach oben da dann
sehe ich dass unbefangen mit der ersten
kategorie und das ist eine 6 1 2 3 4 5
na gut eigentlich gar nicht mal schlecht
ihr kennt mich ja das einzige was ich da
esse fünf euro ich hole das doch ab die
kosten sonst drei euro 99 also hier muss
ich jetzt ehrlich sagen ihr könnt von
mir als lieferheld seite beispielsweise
jetzt doch keine extragebühren für die
sachen nehmen nur weil ich das über euch
gestelle so deutlich dass jetzt gerade
würde mir das jetzt wenigstens geliefert
werden dann ist das ja ok dieser euro
mehr
aber ich würde es doch ab dann brauche
ich das ja gar nicht ihre bestellen dann
kann ich ja auch direkt am mcdrive
bestellen okay ich stelle es jetzt erst
mal zusammen und dann gucken wir weiter
und wir haben ja die zwei ja
cheeseburger okay ein happy meal mit
cheeseburger super hier muss ich jetzt
erst mal sagen das ist nicht gerade ein
ziemlich großer zufall weil das einzige
was ich mir dort manchmal stelle ist
echt ein happy meal mit cheeseburger und
warum ausgerechnet das jetzt kommt keine
ahnung na ja wir machen einfach mal
weiter wir haben hier die 12 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 10 11 12 getränke wusstet ihr dass
es bio milch gibt das habe ich ja noch
nie gehört und jetzt muss ich mich
erstmal wieder aufregen wir haben hier
ein biomineralwasser 0,5 liter für drei
euro
24 und wir haben hier 0,25 liter milch
für zwei euro 79 junge in welcher
galaxie lebt hier so wir haben jetzt
eine 6 das ist glaube ich sogar 123456
es ist bio milch 2 eur 79 finde willig
ist natürlich sehr teuer
es könnte auch daran liegen dass heute
feiert das macht eigentlich gar keine
sind gut zwei sachen doch mehr schaffe
ich ähnlich wir dürfen hier einmal die
sieben jetzt muss ich wieder ganz am
anfang 123 erwartet man wir schauen mal
kurz in die bewertung zwölf mal fünf
sterne sechs mal vier sterne ja und
einen stern gibt es auch sechs mal 3,6
es ist eigentlich ganz gut ich glaube
burger king war auch bei 3,6 er alvaro
schreibt hier did not receive 3 mac
friesi was ist das denn mit friesi also
nur übersetzt ich habe die drei
mccreevys nicht behalten was auch immer
mit friesi sinn und die spielsachen
waren von einer sehr alten kollektion
du hast probleme all war ohne bei marin
hat einfach mal einen bürger gefehlt und
das essen war nicht mehr wirklich warm
und vertrocknet ja so ein bürger zu
wenig ist natürlich immer schlecht und
der rené sieht das ähnlich ich preise
sind doch etwas hoch im vergleich zum
restaurant selbst absolut aber daniela
ist flott mit der bestellung schneller
lieferung genau so wie es sein sollte
komplett einverstanden so gut also wir
hatten die 71 23 4 567 burger und
mcnuggets und wir haben hier die 14
alter 1 2 3 4 5 6 10 11 12 13 14 mcnabb
schicken
ich hoffe dass kann das kann jedoch
nicht ernst meinen dass das ist ja ein
menü wenn man zum laden kauft vier euro
79 für seine macbeth ein rap bei
mcdonald's 479 kosten also ich muss
jetzt wirklich sagen ich tu dir gern
dazu aber ich finde es ist viel zu viel
geld gut also wenn jetzt das happy meal
wir haben die milch wir haben den
maghreb chickens esa und eine sache
bestelle ich noch dazu und zwar aus der
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 sa salat
wir haben wir haben drei verschiedene
salate und ich habe wirklich noch nie
einen salat weil gondelt gegessen
deswegen bin ich gespannt wir haben hier
die 7
ich gehe einfach mal durch 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
ja gut
warte mal ich müsste dass ich eigentlich
der seien 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 ok stimmten
jedoch nicht ich bin dumm den snack
sailer classic haben wir noch dazu drei
euro soll das die kosten für einen salat
von mcdonald also ich werde das jetzt
auf jeden fall so machen ich geb dir
nicht 19 euro aus für diese sachen da
kann ich für eine ganze familie für 19
euro einkaufen sondern ich war einfach
hin und bestellt das was ich gerade ich
muss mir das kurz aufschreiben dann
fahren wir auch schon los also leute bis
gleich warum man heute
wir haben halb eins in der nacht sorgen
ist ein ganz normaler arbeitszeit andere
menschen schlafen schon weil sie morgen
arbeiten müssen nur ich nicht ich fahre
zu mcdonald weil ich 100% zufällig
bestellt habe und hunger hat ich liebe
ein leben das ist echt wirklich ach so
übrigens mal eine kleine frage und zwar
soll ich die felgen vom auto noch mal
ändern jetzt zum sommer inhalt oder soll
ich dir so lassen weil weil die
möglichkeit dazu hätte ich die halt
wieder silber zu machen
aber das war ich noch nicht so ganz
aktionären als noch sagen wollte hätte
mir irgendwer vor zehn jahren gesagt
oder sagen wir vor drei jahren ja alex
in drei jahren sieht dein leben so und
so aus du wohnst da und da und macht das
und das hätte ich geglaubt es ist echt
immer aufregend ich bin mega zufrieden
und das alles nur wegen euch allen also
an dieser stelle mal danke kann man ja
eigentlich nicht auf genug sagen also
trotzdem habe ich hunger bis gleich
sie sehen ja später zwei kameras
gleichzeitig so leute ich bin wieder da
ging eigentlich ganz schön schnell ich
war zehn minuten weg oder so vielleicht
noch zwölf habe ich schon eben ich sage
das ganze hat jetzt elf euro kostet also
ich glaube irgendwie 11 und den nicht
mal etwa zehn euro irgendwas junge leute
an wir haben gerade schon den nächsten
morgen ich bin grad am schnitt vom video
und mir ist jetzt gerade alltäglich ist
aufgefallen dass ich die milch zwar
bestellt hab ich habe sie aber nicht
bekommen ich will zu 100 prozent sicher
die milch habe ich bestellt weil die
noch gesagt hat oder hast du aber glück
dass es die letzte ich habe sogar extra
noch mal nachgeguckt ob ich die
auszusehen weggeschmissen habe aber habe
ich nicht die milch mal nicht dabei war
nicht in der tüte schlecht also da war
ich bei burger mehr zufrieden aber gut
weil ich nur kurz sagen damit ihr euch
nicht wundert also viel spaß jetzt
weiterhin system sonntag habe ich echt
auch noch nie gegessen kabine natürlich
danke werkstück doch diese passion von
diesen salat wie schon gesagt auch nicht
also das probiere ich mal als erstes der
rest ist ja langweilig ich habe mir
jetzt mal mit balsamico dressing
genommen das soll wohl so standard sein
muss ich das doch kräftig durchschütteln
ich kenne so ein typ der ist bei
mcdonald immer nur salat
da denke ich mir da überhaupt hin jetzt
bin ich mal gespannt ich mag salat
eigentlich überhaupt nicht also ich sehe
keinen grund salat zu essen einfach weil
ich der meinung bin so was hat keine
nährstoffe man kann auch ein blatt
papier essen
also die sauce ist schon recht intensiv
da muss ich mal ne pommes nach essen ist
aber an sich für die ernährungsbewussten
menschen heutzutage eine lockere sache
die man mal nebenbei essen kann
allerdings glaube ich nicht zu
vergleichen mit dem visa robert hunger
schreibt in die kommentare
der schmeckt irgendwie voll gesund ich
finde die meisten produkte die man sich
so im fast food laden bestellt die
schmecken auch echte man da merkt man so
am geschmack das ist gerade richtig um
gesund aber hier schmeckt irgendwie ein
bisschen anders ich weiß ja dass das
teil wahrscheinlich absolut gesund ist
aber es schmeckt und das ist die
hauptsache so das happy meal ist leider
ohne spielzeug und was mir hier gerade
sofort auffällt der cheeseburger
der liegt da mindestens schon 20 minuten
hinten drin
der käse ist fast schon an der packungen
dran festgeklebt wie man hier sieht also
das hat wirklich nichts mehr mit dem
cheeseburger zu tun mehr muss ich dazu
ja eigentlich gar nicht sagen wir hatten
jetzt hier in salaten rappen
cheeseburger und nicola eine gute
mischung finde ich für ein gelungenes
abendmahl wenn euch das spontane video
gefallen hat das noch nach oben da
schreibt gerne in die kommentare wo ich
noch bestellen soll und wir sehen uns
wahrscheinlich morgen wieder
ich wünsche einen schönen tag